- Before we say goodbye,
we'd love to play a quick round of!
- Drewth or Dare.
(audience applauds)
- We have Stacey Louise Jacques.
- [Ross] Hi, Stacey!
- Hi.
- [Ross] How are you?
- I'm great, how are you guys?
- Good.
- I love your beautiful
bright colored top.
- Oh, thank you.
- All right, so we're
down. What is it gonna be?
A Drewth or a dare?
- [Stacey] I have a Drewth.
- Okay.
- Have you ever snuck out of
a date before it was over?
(Stacey laughs)
- I wish I knew that I could.
- Oh, yeah, right?
- I am that person, also, who like,
goes to a long winded meal.
Yeah, at 47, I'm finally learning,
don't do a meal on a date.
Is this something everybody knows?
- Oh yeah.
(audience laughs)
- So no, I would like hot tips.
In fact, write in to
TheDrewBarryMoreShow.com
and let us know a good way
to get out of a bad date.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
I have never, ever snuck out of a date.
No, no, no.
I mean, I wanted to leave,
I just was grateful to be there,
'cause it was dinner.
You understand what I'm saying?
(audience laughs)
Like...
It was good.
- What about you, Stacey?
Have you ever snuck out of a date?
- Uh...
Well, I have never actually done it,
but there was a time that I wish I did.
- Yeah, we've all been there.
- You know what you gotta do, the move?
Is give like, your best friend, say,
"Hey, call me 15 minutes into it."
- Everybody knows that!
Everybody knows that the
phone call is a ruse!
- I know, you should see
me fake it, I can do it.
- All right, do it right now.
- Oh, Drew, I'm so sorry.
Oh no! I'm sorry.
My um,
cat is hungry.
I have to go!
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, forget it.
(audience applauds)
Well, thank you, Stacey.
(upbeat music)